I'm getting faster faster than I have
ever been and I wonder if it's because
lately something's chasing me it's my
past the flash for my son I tell it what
you think first off I tell him it's a
dangerous sports
but I told me as a hero dad the man that
put you in here I'm getting close closer
than I've ever been very we have talked
about this I know and I'm done talking
you're not gonna pay for another minute
scribe
show me the future
he's the man that killed my mother I
know what you think today we need your
help hi all right
I know Barry's the flash I love you
good to see you Barry Longford there is
a tsunami heading for the city
the fun's about to begin if you go below
600 miles per hour in an explorer this
is my head freaky I still think about
you all the time and I know you've been
thinking about me too something's
changed between you two I am NOT okay
with it I didn't know any better I think
that you are hiding something from me
what do dr. wells and the reverse-flash
have to do with each other they're the
same person
this is who I think it is anybody that
knows about this in the hell of a lot of
names are doing
I thought Central City was supposed to
be the fun I don't know anything anymore
especially oh I can and can't trust the
real endgame is almost here then face me
now don't let me do this my promise
field Barry Allen you will die
hey youtubers is Charlie as predicted
they posted HD versions of the PaleyFest
trailer so there's gonna be a breakdown
of that biggest takeaway flash versus
flash and eddie thawne killing cops
so just general spoiler warning for
episodes 16 through 19
most the footage is just from the next
three episodes if you saw the trailer
video that I posted a couple days ago
it's almost the same episodes that are
in that just different footage from 16
17 and 18 the first 30 seconds in the
trailer is a lot of clips from previous
episodes just retelling the arc of this
season very trying to solve his mother's
murder find the man in the Yellow suit
find the reverse-flash that killed her
as he thinks the first bit of new
footage we get is of inside STAR Labs
with Cisco tinkering with the atom suit
in the background that's from episode 18
it's called all-star team up you can
think of it as like a soft example of
what the spin-off show might look like
because they're gonna have some flash
characters on that show Victor Garber
will play Martin Stein they haven't
confirmed firestorm because Robbie Amell
wasn't listed on the cast but Andrew
Kreisberg said that they hadn't said
what the name of the show is gonna be
yet because they haven't confirmed a lot
of the actors he's like we don't want to
announce all these people and then have
like the actors that we offered the
roles to say no so they're just waiting
for several people to sign their
contracts before they announce who the
characters are what they're gonna be
doing what the name of the show is if
there's anything that I'm amazed by when
it comes to team flash you know behind
the scenes Andrew Kreisberg Greg
Berlanti
Marc Guggenheim it's their ability to
turn over a pilot quickly they announce
Supergirl just like a little while ago
almost done with the pilot usually
pilots take a little bit longer to shoot
but I'll talk more about that in those
videos now show me the future Gideon I
always let the Gideon scenes it just
this just a teaser I'll be interested to
see if we actually get footage from the
future it certainly makes it sound so
when he said that the show has played
with how far into the future Harrison
wells has been looking most of the time
in the comics when people from the far
future come back in time it's the Legion
of super-heroes like on Smallville that
was a lot of fun that was a Geoff Johns
written episode or it's the AO barred
Thawne reverse-flash and he's from the
25th century but those are all like way
far in advance from where Harrison wells
is looking so they're bringing the
future a little bit closer it's like
less further in the future maybe that's
just to make it more believable
I guess it's us
fantastical when you say someone's from
the 30th century that gets into like
Legion stuff so you know maybe season
two we might start seeing the Legion I
can't wait to see them again that was
one of my favorite episodes
I know Barry has the voice-over over
these Harrison Wells scenes where it
says he's the man that killed my mother
that doesn't necessarily mean he finds
out that Harrison wells is the
reverse-flash right away the way they
cut these trailers together is a little
deceiving footage is not sequential
Cisco very clearly is gonna be the first
one to find out that there's a
connection between Harrison wells in the
reverse-flash but how long he waits
before telling everyone else that
remains to be seen I would say he and
Caitlin are probably gonna figure it out
first and then they'll figure out when
to tell Barry then we have more of the
felicity crossover as much as it's a Ray
Palmer atom crossover it's a Felicity
crossover I like her line later in the
trailer where she says I thought that
Central City was supposed to be the fun
one I always like Ray Palmer intros -
hey everybody
I'm ray how's it going this is my super
suit I need some help the way they've
talked about the atom on the flash this
season implies that he's not gonna be
shrinking but he will be in the future
especially on the spin-off show he's
going to get new tech added to a suit
like Cisco is gonna mess with a suit a
little bit make a little bit better but
we don't know what that's going to
entail small chance of it shrinking but
more likely I think it'll be some other
gadget like it'll be some other weapon
or attack I'll talk about it when I get
to the arrow trailer because there were
some atom footage in that tube but
there's a shot of him using the arc
blaster from his gauntlets here's a big
surprise the canary is also going to
cross over in that all-star team up they
made a couple of jokes about how Cisco
totally geeks out in the Black Canary
like he's totally in love with her
Carlos Valdez did tease in an interview
that we might be seeing some Cisco
romantic you know funny ship type scenes
I don't think he was talking about this
I think he was talking about like legit
love interests and future seasons it
would be nice to see Cisco get some play
this shot of Captain cold with Barry in
the woods this is from episode 16 it's
called rogue time that's where we get to
see gold and glider we get to see her
use her powers or her special gun that
gives her powers she's gonna be like
Captain cold she'll have like a special
STAR Labs gun which it kind of looks
like it turns people to gold based on
this picture it looks like they're
trying to knock over a casino in this
episode but usually they only want money
so that they can get something really
special is it like it's just not for
money itself plans within plans
I am so digging heatwave on this show
is just like cheesy in the best possible
way here's more footage from the weather
wizard episode that's actually episode
15 that's the one that's gonna be this
week so you guys get really excited
about that we're gonna see the Mark
Martin weather wizard here's a better
shot of Mark Hamill from episode 17 we
note the title that is now it's called
tricksters because this trickster the
the classic trickster is gonna be going
up against the modern trickster the Axl
Walker trickster you can also think of
whom is the douchebag trickster that's
kind of what his persona in the comic
books is like I know a lot of people are
really holding out hope that he does
like like a Joker type laugh really he's
doing his character from the original
flash series which sounds a little bit
like the Joker he start on that series
about the same time that he did his
Joker voice for the first time it was
that it was relatively close so maybe
one of those influenced the other if
anybody goes to a convention and gets to
talk to him you can ask him about that
the trickster says Barry has to run
above 600 miles an hour or the bomb will
explode around his wrist I'll be
interested to see if they have any Keanu
Reeves speed jokes but this would be a
really good opportunity to show Barry
developing his phasing power like
phasing his body through solid objects
so that he can just phase the wristband
off before it explodes here we get to
see Joe West with Gorilla Grodd
the interesting thing about Grodd so far
is that we don't really know what his
plan is he's just hanging out in the
sewers obviously he wanted to kill
general Eiling although we see him later
in the trailer so we know he's not dead
but what else is he doing what is his
grand plan for central city and keystone
city jesse Martin talked about filming
scenes with a big-ass monkey at
PaleyFest so that's really funny it's
once we get to the last 30 seconds of
the trailer that the [ __ ] starts to hit
the fan we start dealing with the Barry
Irish plot so you know very clearly
they're going to be hooking up sometime
in the next couple of episodes and it's
kind of caused a big rift in their
relationship their collective
relationship with Eddie Thawne because
he is going out with iris right now not
gonna be super happy as we see from the
trailer this footage of him clocking him
in the casino that's from the rogue time
episode episode 16 so clearly in episode
15 there's gonna be some sort of like
Barry iris moment I know they are
predestined from the comic books to get
married and have this big relationship
I'm not feeling it so much on the show
right now I'm just gonna give the show a
chance to develop that and I'll make up
my mind afterwards the real WTF is Eddie
Thawne chewing gum and casually killing
cops like it's
no big deal because he's chewing gum
like a total [ __ ] either something
happened to change him like some villain
on the show affected his mind like the
way Barry's mind was affected when he
went after Oliver during flash versus
arrow like either that's something like
that or he is gone completely off the
rails because this footage is just from
like the next three episodes I think
it's a little too early for him to go
crazy so soon like just because his
girlfriend kisses another man doesn't
mean he's gonna go start killing cops
clearly something else is going on here
but open up a tab in chrome for
villainous eddie thawne they've already
confirmed that he is connected to the
reverse-flash lineage they just haven't
said how him doing terrible things is
obviously the first step on the path to
that I would say of all the best Eddie
Thawne theories I've seen one you know
he is either a cobalt blue
Malcolm Thawne which is like a cousin
like a relative of Barry Allen that
ended up being raised by thawne's
he's hunter zolomon with a Thawne name a
cop that goes bad and gets reverse-flash
powers or he's just straight-up the
grandfather or a great-grandfather of
Harrison wells once we actually see some
of this stuff play out we'll have to
modify some of our theories I think
they'll wait till the finale to
completely explain the relationship like
will learn about Harrison wells and
we'll learn about Eddie Thawne but we
won't learn about how they're connected
till like the very last episode Cisco
Caitlin and Barry talking about Harrison
wells being the reverse-flash
so like the team the team is like slowly
figuring things out and trying to decide
what to do about it
they're not screaming at each other so
you know clearly they're trying to make
up their minds here we have an awesome
shot of Quentin Lance doing a crossover
that's probably also from episode 18 so
think about it this way we have Black
Canary Quentin Lance and the atom all
crossing over all Felicity to aunt
Felicity so quite a few characters
actually we don't know whose murderer
they're investigating but this could be
someone that Harrison wells killed in
the past very far in the past because it
looks like the corpse has been decaying
for a long time if you remember like Joe
is full on going after Harrison wells
like he's trying to build a case against
them he is convinced that he's the man
that killed Barry's mother here's a nice
shot of the reverse-flash going after
irises reporter friend this is just you
know part of irises investigation
against STAR Labs here just like one of
the most fun scenes ever Barry punching
himself out there's a long history in
the comics of flash going up against
himself for like the reversal
fighting other versions of himself when
you get into time travel you see that a
lot this could be from episode 15 that's
the first time we'll see him time travel
but once he does he'll probably continue
to do it so this could be from a future
episode like 16 17 18 19 here's a really
awesome shot of Emily Kinney as the
bug-eyed bandit and everyone wants to
learn more about hive on arrow but this
would definitely be a backdoor to that
organization just because it fits with
the bee motif she's gonna be more of a
felicity villain then she's gonna be a
team flash villain in case I didn't say
it before this is from the team-up
episode episode 18 here's a really
awesome scene of Sisko turning around
and seeing Harrison wells standing up so
you know very clearly Cisco is gonna be
the one to figure out what Harrison is
doing first very clearly he is more
emotionally connected to Harrison wells
he's kind of like his surrogate dad this
light saber here that Grant Gustin has
and it's so funny to think of it as a
light saber this is whether wizards
control rod or the best Easter Egg for
it
it looks like weather wizard doesn't
need a control rod like he did in the
comics the original comics so this might
be a way for them to take his powers
away it might be a nice twist on that
how awesome is it that they have a
lightsaber and then two episodes later
you have Mark Hamill Luke Skywalker Jedi
Master I'll be really interested to see
if someone tries to steal this prop off
the set after season 1 is over this mask
here is just more police right here like
upgraded police right gear as we saw in
previous episodes the STAR Labs people
have been outfitting the Central City
Police Department with equipment based
on the powers that the Rogues have so
just a reminder episode 15 airing this
week be sure to subscribe to get my
video I'll post it right after the
episode airs it's gonna be so much to
talk about time travel the reverse-flash
weather wizard also i'm working on the
arrow trailer I'm gonna do a breakdown
to that I'll post that in just like a
couple hours while you guys wait for me
to post the arrow trailer breakdown you
can click here to catch up on arrow this
season coming back this Wednesday and
you can click here for my last flash
trailer breakdown separate footage but
from the same episodes thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys all in a
little bit let's all do the thing
you